[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
no no
[Applause]
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
the account
[Applause]
[Music  ]
o no
[Music]
no no
i
ladies and gentlemen please
welcome to the stage isaac
hernández country manager of google
cloud iberia
hello good morning everyone and
welcome to google next madrid for
us it is truly a pleasure to have you
with us today  us and we hope that it will be a
successful and profitable session for each
one of you just three months ago we
celebrated in san francisco the biggest
event that google cloud has held
to date google next in san
francisco a few weeks ago we
extended that event to london already  tel
aviv and today we are proud to
have spain and more specifically
madrid as the fourth city
in the world in which we celebrate this launch
of google cloud through google
next 2017
for all of us who work in
information technologies we are
living in a truly exciting world
perhaps there is no other better word to
define this moment advances in
information technologies and in
information systems in general are
generating transformation change and
opportunity and when we see what mobility does not
the cloud and more recently
artificial intelligence is doing
for all of us we realize
that things that until very recently were
really impossible today are possible and
are a reality that is the kind of
power we are facing and the
opportunity we have  ahead in
front of all of us and that it is a
certain responsibility again of those of us
who work both in supply
and demand in what refers to
information technologies
we have been working
hard in recent years and
incorporating many of the comments
feedback  and suggestions for improvement that you
have been making to us and in fact in  in the
last 12 months we have launched
about 500 improvements, updates and
products within our
google cloud platform, in fact today
we will have the opportunity to tell you about
some of the
most recent most interesting news that have been
launched practically every week
since google  cloud was announced a
few years ago
more important than products and
services of course the real
protagonists are our customers and
we can say that we have multiplied by
two in recent months the number of
customers who are betting on and
adopting google cloud in their  different
colors and flavors we are literally talking
about millions of companies of all
sizes, from startups to super
large multinationals from all
industries and representatives from all
countries that are betting on the
google cloud to make their
projects and business models a reality,
not only  we have clients nothing would be
po  possible without the group of partners with
whom we work for us, it is
absolutely essential to develop an
ecosystem of partners that accompany us
and accompany you in this type of
project today we already have more than
13,000 partners worldwide of
all types of software manufacturers
integrators of solutions, large
consulting companies that are
big players in the
enterprise world and that have been
manufacturing products and solutions for many years
capable of making the
most ambitious projects that you have to
face come true, and it is also for
us today  We are proud to have a
lot of Spanish partners who
join us today in Google Next and who
have made an
important effort to be with us today and
in the 'bous and in the places that
you have outside in the outside of  the room
because you will be able to see some of the latest
advances some of the solutions of the
things that they are doing to  other
clients and that we are sure will
be of interest to each and every
one of
you finally in google we have also
grown from a people point of
view to be able to provide the service you
need in the last 12 months we have
multiplied again by more  the
number of people is two and in fact we are still
recruiting in fact someone has left me
a resume this morning we are still
recruiting within the company and
basically recruiting
technical profiles architects people specialized
in the different big data
solutions in the different internet solutions
of the  application development things
in all the different
facets of what the cloud can
make a reality today and we continue to grow and
we will continue to grow to accompany
the commitment that in some way
you customers are making for all of
us
google celebrates its 19th anniversary this
year  from minute 1 we have been
a cloud native cloud company and
we are proud  We are proud to have built
probably some of the
most powerful data centers on the planet, and the
size of our data centers is
clear through the products and
services that we deliver to
users. We have a
very large set of products and services, but
seven of them each.  one of them already
exceeds a billion people
in use every day we talk about more than a
billion people from the search engine more than a
billion people from youtube more
than a billion people from
chrome maps of some of the other products
that  they accompany us and in fact we
have recently announced just a
few weeks ago that some of these
products already touch two billion
people as is the case of android or
this week we have announced that
google photos already has more than one
billion downloads from our
application store
the philosophy with which we have built
our cloud is a philosophy by
which what we intend  s is for
developers and IT departments to be
able to produce and manufacture code
fast in an intelligent way and to be
able to deliver it in a secure and
scalable way through our
cloud platform solutions 7
products with more than a billion
people google cloud platform
today it is also a product with more than a
billion end users companies
like pokemon go like snap chat like
evernote like spotify that have opted
for google cloud platform all of them
every day also serve another
billion people of end
users through our  own technologies
and as I told you before,
our philosophy for manufacturing our
cloud, what it has done is in some way
reflect the way in which we
face and deal with our
engineering, our way of dealing with the
business and in a certain way they are a reflection
of the values that  google has as a
company and there are four values that we ha
e used to  To build
the four are the values that we are going to use a
pillars of the presentation that
e are making to you at this time,
in the first place, security, nothing is im
ortant if security and reputation fail us, our c
ients in our c
mpanies are in trouble and that
s true  for the smallest startup
that may be in the room and it is
also true for the largest
multinational that we can have at
any given time, security is
trust and it is the foundation on
which to build everything else is undoubtedly
the most important  secondly,
we live in a time when
data, context and intelligence should
increase
people's capabilities and provide us with more
intelligence on all machine
learning issues and all issues that are not
natural to google within our
accessible mission all the information in the world
and to be able to offer it in a simple
and universal way in third place yes
While it is true that computers have
changed the way we work, we think
that there is an important challenge to move
from individual talent to
collective intelligence and values such as coope
ation are fundamental to face
volatile and u
certain complex and ambiguous search environment such as the one that
we have ahead of us and
we will also talk about it throughout
today's session and lastly we talk about
opening a cloud that has to be
open and by open I don't
just mean I don't just mean a commitment to
open source I don't just mean  I mean a
lot of apis that are easy to
integrate and access, I also mean
to give you control and power in such a way that
all the architecture and all the
cloud rules are completely in
your hands, as I was saying, these are going to
be the four  pillars that are going to support
the discussion and the
presentation that we have throughout
today, thanks again to all of you for
your attention and without further delay  we are going
to start the session and we are going to
start it precisely for security and
for this
I would like to invite yolanda to the village
of the google strategic accounts team
thank you all very much
[Music]
many times isaac let's talk about security
in 2016 spain was the subject of  more than
105,000 cyberattacks twice as many as in
2015 five times more than in 2014
forecasts for 2017 are not at all
reassuring said isaac and I
totally agree that it is essential to
support the trust of our customers
the loyalty of our customers in
a good  security mechanism at google
we have it very clear we are a
public cloud provider and we are extremely
careful to offer the best
privacy guarantee protection mechanisms and regulatory compliance to
our clients many times in
companies security is used as an
excuse not to  make the decision to
upload to the public cloud when in reality
this should be  a
weighty argument precisely in that
decision-making exercise in the move to the
public cloud and to give us a piece of information tell you
that in the last three years google
has invested more than 30 billion
dollars in improving its infrastructure and
this has been significantly  also
an investment dedicated to security to
protect our infrastructure and the
services we offer to customers and
we do this by using our
security experts more than 750 experts
recognized in the market
security experts who are continuously
improving and adapting our
infrastructure and our  products
to offer greater protection to
our clients
in google the data is encrypted at rest
when it is stored it is encrypted in
transit when we carry out any
communication between services or between
services and clients on
both our Jesuit collaboration platform and our cloud
with cloud platform  we apply mechanics  We use
very sophisticated encryption and we
protect our clients against
typical denial-of-service attacks
and it is precisely to protect ourselves against
denial-of-service attacks that
we make use of our global network, a
network that hosts our
data centers in both America and Europe
as well as in  asia and that are interconnected
by submarine fiber pulled by google,
a network that allows us to reach
any user with low latency
regardless of the place from
which a network is connected, we work on
all google services including
youtube and in which we are especially
rigorous in  take care of security the
protection of customer
data high availability and good
response times in fact our
engineers have created
proprietary architectures both for the construction
of our own servers on
scale we host our products as
well as the communication protocols
the devices of  connectivity  ad of the
different servers housed in
data centers worldwide, this
infrastructure is also subject to
improvement measures
to the point that we even
simulate partial failures of this
non-global infrastructure to mitigate the risk of
impact on the service in the event of any
incident in  the future also since
2010 we offer incentive programs
for hackers that what they do is
reward monetarily those hackers
who find vulnerabilities before
they deprive attackers exploit these
roads so that google can
remedy these
security problems before we find
incidents
and if google is known for something in the
market it is for its vocation for innovation
also in security we are
incorporating innovations in fact at the
event in march this year in san
francisco we
announced one of our new
developments in a security environment
a chip called  specific purpose titan
lodging  in our
servers or in our peripherals and
that what the cebit allows is the
undue manipulation of the code at the level
of rivers
other technological innovations that
we have included in recent times
is two-step authentication this what
it basically allows is to fight against
difficult attacks  recently the
national cryptological center
published the data for 2015 in 2015 in
spain the economic cost associated with
phishing attacks phishing attacks
exceeded 60
million euros in the
europe ranking we seemed like the second country
with the most phishing attacks by  behind
the united kingdom this is fundamentally the
main problem that
companies face in the security
environment phishing and we have it available to
implement immediately even
in your particular environment in
your particular gmail accounts
this mechanism simply needs
to be configured  and there are different
possibilities either  n generate this
dynamic code that complements the
identification of the user with a
username and password through
software as I say or through
hardware notification keys like the ones we
use in google on a daily basis, they are keys
that allow us to automate that generation
of the code  so that it is easier to
adopt this passos authentication mechanism
and that they also already solve
the ability to do it from mobile devices
this works with nfc communication with
mobile devices in short, there are no longer
any excuses to protect ourselves against these
identity theft attacks and I
encourage you to  that you activate it
immediately both in your
private environment and in your companies
other innovations that we announced at the
san francisco event were
identity our proxy, a new mechanism
to protect access to
applications that what it does is innovate
in the environment  to apply
access policies to applications without ten  er to
rely on perimeter security without
having to use vpn without having to
configure very complex rules in
corporate firewalls we also
announced a new
data loss prevention data loss prevention data loss prevention app and dlp api
sensitive but more
than we found out what this
new app consists of and I am going to give way to the next
speaker, one of
them is that he is going to make us a demo of this
product that is in demos forward
javier
hello everyone
good morning thanks for being here good
I am going to show you a demo with an
application that we have assembled that
can surely be a very
familiar application for many of you, it is a
customer management chat application,
in this case, I am Javier, I am a
support person for the company acme,
which is  a multinational DIY company and
I am attending to a client
named lis as you can see in this chat to be
able to attend to alice I need to
identify her I need  to give me some
information to know that it is
a client
but now that you see here it is that in addition
to giving me certain information that I
require such as the telephone number or the
name alice gives me more information in
this case an American client gives me  his
social security number and on top of that
he uploaded a photo to me is too much
information what we see here is that there are
certain applications such as a
business chat to support
end users that it does make sense for them to
exchange personal information
however what we do not want them to  happens is
that this type of personal
personal information permeates other systems that
should not store it and this is a
real possibility
for this what I am going to do is
show you how our app
and dlp protection from information leaks work
I am going to end the chat
coralys
and what is going to happen now is that in
our enterprise chat application it
communicates with the dlp pen and the
bp engine  it starts to work and is capable of
identifying different types of
information that we have available to
our clients, there are about 40 types of
information and you can see here that it is
beginning to classify that information
and is censoring it in this way we
would prevent this information from passing
into systems  To those of us who do not want it to
happen, to give an example, imagine
that by regulation you have a system that
is storing these conversations and
you do not want that
personal information to be in this is
the filing system or to give us
another example and more general than  you have an
analytics system because you want to do
aggregate analytics on customers
to serve them better but you don't want
the people who are doing you want
on that system to also be able
to get that personal information
here you see that we have censored
alice's name we have there good my  name
also obviously your phone
number your security number  ad social but
lepe's pencil is going even a
little deeper and is being able
to process the image and detect
which fields should not be
shown and which should be hidden
in this case it would also be
alice's social security number  and your name and
surnames,
well to show you that this is not a
chat demo that we have rotated here and
well a bit of cardboard-mache what we
want to do is also show something
else and it is with a camera that I have
connected to this equipment we are going to  to use
an example of a credit card
obviously
this is not a real credit card
because if it were, then it would expose me that
many of you will start buying
with cash like crazy in the audience and that
is not
what you see here  is that I have the
16 digits of the credit card number
so what I am going to do is
recognize this and also pass it through the
lepe api to see if the api is capable
of filtering that information
Well, this is a monkey effect, it
's an effect of the expected- in any
case, because if you look closely, these 16
digits look like a credit card number,
but they are not, they are actually
the numbers that do not have the check sum
corresponding to a card.  of credit
because what we are going to do is take a
credit card that does have the
corresponding numbers although they should
work
we are going to use this other one if you look
at the first one it ended in 1 this one that
I am going to use now ends in 5100 and
this yes  that it has the wrong sex,
so when we do the recognition,
we do have lepe's pencil that
was effectively censoring the 16
digits of the credit card,
so
thank you
or summarize, we have an api that is requested
from lepe, protection against
information leaks that  it is the same and also that it
is behind services such as gmail and
drive it implements the same type of
characteristics that allows us with more
than 40 predefined rules and that
they continue to evolve we are adding
more and more rules to be able to
strictly control in which systems personal
information should or should not reside,
thank you very much,
yes, cesc racial javier,
security is equally important, it is equally important to
accompany our clients so that they
comply with the regulations
in force in google we assume
all the responsibility as those in charge
of the treatment of the data of our
clients and those responsible for the data
are you, you are our clients and
we offer you all the certifications and
reports of periodic audits that
we do in google precisely to
guarantee that  Regulatory compliance in
any of the sectors with which
we work and in any of the
regions where we offer our
services and products in Spain Google
both on its Jesuit collaboration platform
and on its
cloud platform Google Cloud Platform complies with
Spanish protection law  of data with the l
operates and offers those responsible for the
data to customers two
compliance alternatives the first of them is
based on the certification known as
safe port
driver session you know that this was approved
in July of last year it is the substitute
for what  which was previously known as the
safe harbor framework and we have been
offering it on Google since September of
last year, the
second alternative is based on
contractual clauses,
clauses that have been recently
approved by all
European data protection agencies,
including the Spanish
and  In addition, we continue to work
intensively as we have been doing
in recent times to also prepare
compliance with the new
European gpr data protection regulations for our clients.
We are modifying our
contractual terms so that clients who
trust us also have a plan with
our new regulations.  which is aimed
at protecting  better European data,
in short, I hope that in this
talk I have achieved my objective, which
was really to argue the
firm conviction that we have in
Google that the data, that
important asset of companies, is
safer in Google's public cloud than
the infrastructures of the companies and
in this way we can compare the
current moment with what happened
more than 150 years ago with the incorporation
of banking into the market many of us respect
here I certainly include myself we have
heard stories from our grandparents
in which we  They used to say that their savings, a
wad of bills, were kept under the
mattress or behind a brick in the
wall of their houses, and yet
today no one questions that
money is much safer when
protected by a bank than in our private homes,
but more than  Talking to you
about the banking sector, you are going to allow me
to present the next opponent, it is
a great honor for me to
present  tar santiago alarcón who is in
the engineering team defining there
is nothing the new global platform of a
totally emblematic client and a
benchmark for innovation and
early adoption of new technologies a
client of which we are very proud
nothing more and nothing less than  I see see
welcome Santín
and thank you
very much from Holland
wow
well I'm Santi Alarcón I've
been responsible for Google Cloud
Platform in BV for six years and I'm also
extremely lucky to be part of
the global term team, it's not because it's
being built  the tools
with which eleven thousand developers the
developments of úbeda are going to work in
the future the first thing of course to
thank google for allowing me to
tell a little about our experience
here and they expressed my enormous enormous
pride in being part of
google  next 2017 de madrid' and the
enormous emotion of being here
you will see in the year 2011 bbva was
immersed in  a process of
transformation digital transformation
that process began in 2007 and
this continues not to continue at
that time because there were many,
many initiatives of various
depths to a lot of things that
we wanted to do the best known the best
known above all because in  tone like
this because google sorry you
see went to google it didn't take your
email it took the tig signature everyone
we're not going to google
the result has been spectacular
we wanted to use it as a lever
of change and that's what it has  past, that
is, the transcendence within the
organization has been absolute,
this is surely what it is, well,
what I can say is that the
vision of the cloud for the 134,000 or more
than 134,000 employees of the bank has also
changed completely. You can think of
co-edition and  global document cogeneration
imagine people from
argentina from the usa from venezuela
from spain working on the
same document at the same time  I'm sorry that happens every day
every ten hundred times okay
but also to think about instant messaging
also to think about
videoconferencing in a super
simple way also thought I know about the use
of sites for information issues the
use of groups
like me and it's  how we imagine how
we imagine
working in a different way now now that
we can't think of how
what happens is that I didn't come to
talk about it
in 2011
there were more projects and another
big emblematic project was to
articulate a worldwide intranet
so that  to connect all
those users and I tell you we are more than
134,000 we are spread over 38 countries
etc. etc. so how do we make
an intranet that connects us all at the
same level that also serves as a
gateway for all these
collaborative tools that I was
commenting on  or that they were part of those
initiatives and that, furthermore, it will not penalize well,
man, if I am in Argentina and
I am in Spain, well  it is that we
all enter a little well well at the same level
not that we do not have a penalty for
where we are then the problem this
is the problem that must be solved
imagine this is the scenario
and we begin to think we are going to think
well I will remember several times that
that was 2011 ok so good
centralized solution that's it we put
everything in our data centers in spain'
and to consume the internet of course that had a
problem and yes but if i come from
buenos aires today or inside from mexico or
i inside from san francisco  I'm going to
have a penalty in latency and
apart from the consistency of the data there
I'm going to have a little problem
well distributed solution okay what I
do is that I copy the application in
several places well this is much worse
we in this yes that is to say
that we have  a lot of experience in
distributing software worldwide with
all our data centers and this
poses a lot of challenges since
I don't know about  heterogeneous security heterogeneous
hardware issues heterogeneous systems
that is complicated it is
also complicated these two solutions had another
problem and that is that they went over the bbva network
for us that is important it could not
go over the debt they were
punishing us the network with which  we
serve customers then, well, as
you can imagine, we already took another
path, we did not decide to go to google,
we went to the cloud, google already dedicated
these 2011, what were the drivers
to go to the google cloud, well, this
is what I expose here, that is, this  It's
what we're thinking about
Google's offer, which seems
interesting to us, well, it has a
worldwide CDN automatically,
great because it still has a
software distribution problem, at least on
the front end, and then they also replicate
the data from  great automatic way
I no longer have a problem of what I do with the
data
then it also replicates the processes
l  fantastic applications
like this a mexican enters the
intranet or in any other process that
we have started in ngai it turns out
that you start executing that
process you start telling about it in the
treatment to the one closest to him which
is fantastic or security  we
leveraged on security the same
security we have for gmail no
basically that is
identification with it but we thought it was a
good idea hey well yes
what I'm going to tell you now is good for us because it
surely seems exaggerated I'm
sure but what we discovered  It was
2011, what we discovered was
a new world for us
, that is, what encouraged us was what
I told you, what we discovered was this,
and suddenly we discovered that we were
working with containers,
think, for example, that in 2011,
well, listen to what  to work with a good if
directly with it to see metal because it is the
most usual thing you do not put your system there
etcetera but to work with something that is
a closed 30 that has its own
tools that runs the same
locally as in production that also
allows me things like starting in
milliseconds and not in minutes
because it was not that common you have to
think that although the idea of
ners is very very old becau
e the  The first version of dockers is
from 2013, I think it created something that
we discovered things after the issue
of microservices and the application
that today is fundamental, well, this
was totally natural, that is, it was
the one who asked us to
do more and more processes  self-contained
and that these processes were consumed
by apis the same thing 2011 you have to
think that in 2010 in 2010 twitter
was still monolithic and then that kind
of thing because now that they are so
common it is not what to do
because it was not so  of course not and in line with
all this came elastic
scaling elastic scaling let's see is google
grows horizontally theoretically to
infinity
this is theory p  But it is horizontal
because it also falls, what it does is
grow elastically
if you see the graph that has been placed there,
what that graph shows and those lines
that are painted black are the peaks in
demand, that is, when demand arrives
what does the gaes do, what instances when
demand falls this is real this has
been for a couple of days from an
internal system of lubia that as you can see
when entering the lurking tomorrow it
raises 600 instances when the
demand for the product falls what happens  it is
that those instances are destroyed or you
act you are using what you need all the time
and nothing else attached to this
we also had the deployments in one
click well I don't know how you have experienced
many deployments surely yes of
all colors for us to be able to
upload  the version of something every time
you want to select a specific version
and set it by default and
that immediately be in
production seemed like magic directly to us  In other
words, you didn't have to talk to anyone, you
put it into execution, that's it, what is
connected with know ops, that is, we
take care of developing, we don't
take care of making the garden of the
databases, we don't take care of putting the
base software, no  we take care of nothing
that the only thing we do is develop
this it was also possible by another
mechanism that catches our
attention which is the console itself everything
pivots in the console through the
project axis you are doing a project and
you have everything you need  all the
tools that google gives you I don't know
the storage the processing the
login
the training the art the alert and everything
is accessible through the console and
finally the issue of security
this is impressive you speak for us
at that time it was that  We were
delighted to have the
identification part, the authorization part,
well, also because we
do it off great, but there are
many more secure  ities according to what I had
before in the Netherlands, that is, there are a lot of
aspects to take into account,
well, for example, do any of
you know how many
security fixes we have had this year or
last year, how many, how many fixes, sorry,
that's not it either  wonderful, that is,
this is what Google gives me, I don't do it, that is,
security is also taken care of by
Google at that level,
the things that, more than the bad, are a bit
the ones that we did not like so much
historically, that is, in the year 2011  Well, of
course, the learning curve of
understanding that what you were working on
is with an execution stack and not with
anyone or with bm, so it will be complicated,
that is, at the beginning, because we had
problems with this, it did not enter
our heads much, so that curve
it cost then also the platform itself
is quite rigid at the beginning in
that you only have a number of
languages 64 languages you have a specific st
ck some specific libraries but it is radicall
changed with c  on serious
flexible' because it is already possible to use
docker to run
to run in that it is in
general availability this year it has
been two three months
so you already have a lot more flexibility
than at the beginning and then the topic of the
data store these funny  of course
now we all know a lot of I don't know
which we all have done things with I
compose with a lot of tools
that now but this is 2011 think
people who had been normalizing tables for 10 years
and now you go and tell them that they
have to denormalize well then  there
was some friction there unit works
we have some anecdote in any
case the changes are always difficult
you know
that it is the boss because I am telling you
how it started what we learned at the
beginning but what is that today well today
we have more than 700 applications
working no  only on the internet of
course but anything that is done
internally is done in gcp then we have more
than 200 million a  pícola per month, that is, it
is something impressive, zero is more than
800,800 thousand machine hours per month of nga,
imagine the number of machines that
we would have to have in bbva to
meet only this demand, okay, then
we have 15 terabytes that astor we have
twenty terabytes in bit  query I don't know
we use all the tools that
google cloud phone has for a lot of
things it would be very good to also talk about
big data or it would be very good to talk about
massey learning but I think that
is for another talk we don't do a lot
well that's it  a little outline of how
we work in general yes our pattern
pattern
and well roll up much more what does
this mean but since it has meant to
drink the experience
of working at google working with boss
p well as I told you at the beginning
we are immersed in a project  of
transformation of how our
developers work if that process has
as a map as a blueprint as a blueprint
has hcp is the global term
of bbva est  á based on fp is based on the fact
that it takes many ideas from fsp and from the
previous experience that we have had gsp
wheat
okay and a little to finish I
would like or want to comment on what it can
mean for your company because it is
very good it is very good that it  see well,
have resources and invest gcp etc.
or that spotify
evernote is worth it but the interesting thing about
this I think the message to deliver
is no no no from your startup with your
friends your startup financed your company
it doesn't matter you work with the same
infrastructure as  others
work you work with the same
innovative tools that others work
with that others can work with, in addition
to a very fair way in terms of
payment, in addition to a very fair way
in terms of how to reach those
resources, also without having  to invest
in profiles that perhaps are not the core
of your business, that is, since, for
example, I think all the time about
osa security in bv how can you not  er
another way we have armies of
people dedicated to security
armies and it is normal many
people from safe houses how
could I transfer that how could I
transfer that to a smaller company
is that it is very complicated it is very
complicated I think that in the end it will
that gps translates not only into cost savings,
but of course not only access
to technology but of course
a lot of emphasis is placed on security
and the focus on your business
and well I think this is all it
is  I have to tell you today what I do
want is to give way to Israel Hello,
I'm going to tell you a couple more things
[Applause]
Well, thank you very much, Santín, and the
truth is that it is a great luxury to listen to you and
after seeing you I hardly know what else
say why he has done everything
explained and he has explained everything
perfectly
santiago has told us as companies
like you how our clients
use the cloud and our products
to change the business for cam  They change the
way of making software to
revolutionize the bank and we
also hope that all our companies and in
that we want that we want to continue
telling that is my part I want to
tell you specifically in the
data part how data is the material
with which we build the  companies of the
future as data is very
important to be able to continue
building projects and
as it has of course been very
important for the baby and also as it
has been key to being able to develop
the products that we offer you every
day all the products that you have heard
with  more than a billion users the
seven applications and also to
understand the business of the future
but the first thing that any
company does the first try 2 or the first
change in the first trick to
do when you set up a database
is that you have  to choose what
happens we have
traditional sql databases much easier to
manage
we have problems d  and limit
insertions in limit insertions in lashkar
abilities we can grow up to a
maximum size and you have the other
alternative that is doubled
mentioned santi which are
non-sql databases where you are going to be able to
grow horizontally what is happening to us
what
they do not believe from google we believe that you should not
have to choose you do not need to
choose you can or we believe that it would not be
necessary to choose
and that is why we present you today spanair which
is the first database in which you
will not be able to you will not need to
choose you will  to be able to use sql as
you were using up to now
we are going to take care of all
the security management of the el xardín operating system
between the different systems
we are going to take care of the replication
between the different geographical areas and
we are going to guarantee an
automatic replication between  all of them and the good thing
is that we have been using it for
quite some time within google spanair it
is the base of  data that is behind
products such as adwords, you
can imagine what all that
bunch of transactions are, the bid and the
auctions that are behind the ads
and do all that in real time to the
volume of queries that we have in
google, okay  we have solved the
problem for that and now we can
offer it to you but well what is
the trick
you will wonder how google has been able to
solve a problem that others have been
trying to solve one of the big
problems that we have
all been trying to solve from all over the world  from
haiti well it's simple there are two
parts first it's true time true time is
our timestamp service
with which we say exactly
what time it is in any of the
transactions we have this service it
is based on atomic clocks corrected
with gps and we are able to know  at the
local level within each data center, which
is now when a transaction happens, that
is what allows us to guarantee c  hen
the masters are replicating each
other that the transactions occur
in the correct order, that is, strong
consists in whether, in English,
very strong consistency or
consistent selection that looks good, but of course
you already know the speed of light,
I have not done one  transaction in tokyo
i have made a transaction in london by the
way you have noticed that
we already have a west 2 in london
i have made a transaction in london i have
made a transaction in virginia and yes
you can have it replicated now but you
need to move the
transaction data from  one to another place and there what
we have is our network as yolanda has
said
we have our own network
built in your in our
andromeda hardware that sheen when you
will already know it capable of addressing a
petabyte per second and what that
allows us is to guarantee that  even if
one of the fiber optic cables
that we have by the sea falls or even if
one of the machines fails, we will find
routes  alternatives and with that we can
guarantee strong consistency
but well I think that it is better that
I tell you about it is to see it live and that
rafa diaz tells us it is israel good to
show you all the power of a
database like spanair I am going to start with
the principle for how to create it imagine
that you have to create a database
with the four attributes that you
mentioned before
'israel a database that is
relational that is to say that it is sql that is
multi-regional it is available and
that it can deliver it for example the
three  continents with high availability
that is transactional with
strong consistency and also that it scales
horizontally if it had to do that with
traditional technologies because it would have
to install the machines on the
different continents configure the
configure the network and a new very
important part because if it configured a base
of data like these distributed and
connected in several continents the
fiber network has  And it has to be
very good, very good performance and
low latency, then I would also have to
configure the rules for high
availability and then I have the operational part left, that
is, what happens if I have to
modify the database or I have to
update the or  I have to put
patches on them
because this in the end because it becomes a
nightmare not when it comes to configuring and
maintaining this network with clau de spanair which is
a managed service this is
extremely simple from a
console you can set the name of the
instance select the
main continent where I want to display the
number of nodes, for example 10 number of
logical nodes that spanair has, I give it
create and I already have a database with
the 4 attributes that I mentioned before,
but we are going to see a database
because it is obviously the  I just
created and it is empty it has no content
inside we are going to see a
working database this is
a company database  that sells tickets
worldwide, that is to say, it is a company that
has a database spread over
the three continents to sell
tickets for events such as concerts,
games, etc. and anyone from
anywhere in the world can buy
from this database, so they have to
fulfill 22 very important functions
here first a ticket is sold
once and only once
that is to say that if a person from the usa
buys for a guns 'n'
roses concert here in madrid and another person
buys from japan then that ticket
cannot be  sell twice and then that the
latency experienced by the user
is minimal then this is what
clau de spanair does which then deploys the
database across the three continents and
guarantees those functions that we have
mentioned before here as you can see on the
screen they are entering  tickets
at a speed of about 600,000 per
minute this is the only thing we are
simulating because this is a
real demo with spanair totally  nte live the
only thing we are talking about here is the
entry of tickets through nine
classes of cuber net is that they are
plugging tickets at a rate of about 600
thousand per minute and you see a little with the
speed and latency that they
are experiencing  well what is the
database that is behind in the
database that manages this
database despite being distributed
globally it is a single database
this is the schema this is
the database schema it is made up of
several tables joined together by
join and then if you look closely there is a table
on the bottom right which is the one with a
billion records which is the one that
contains information about
the tickets that can enter me from
anywhere in the world but I already said it
is one  single database the garden that
is below say the division that
google already implements below for you you
see a single database like that
how is this what happens if I want to make
a cuera a cuera  and on that
database I have to worry about that article
launches a quera these a
sql relational database for I can
execute this query while the
database continues to work I do not need to
stop it or reconfigure it and nothing
like that  This body, for example, what it is
going to do to me is when I execute it, it is going to
tell me the three events that
still have more tickets available on
yesterday's date, no, well then, well,
it executed the query on that
database and tells me the  events that
had more tickets without selling the date as
of yesterday and I already said the most
important thing is what you don't see from here the
thematic sardine boat that is below
makes it spanair with which I don't
have to worry about doing is that
you are complex I continued to implement this
distributed database of mine
well what happens yes because well this is
a company that normally
evolves it changes what happens if
the database for example
the esq  uema of the database I need to
change it and add a new table add
a new column modify the
previous schema of course spanair supports
schema updates without the need
to stop the database
and what happens if for example I need to
grow the database horizontally
with more with more nodes because
I simply edit the instance and go from 25 nodes
which is the one that had the 25 logical 12 which
is the one that had the number of nodes of the
ticketing company I put 50 and
I grow horizontally to 50 nodes without
need  again to stop the
database automatically practically
I have the nodes of the
new ones left the 25 additional new ones
well
this service is part of the
managed services of google cloud
with which the same as app engine the same
as compute in the same  What other
services is managed by our
multi-cloud monitoring tool,
which is to be a driver? Here we see, for
example, some of the analytics
what is the driver can pick up for
us like for example the putt in the
in the database or the size of the
database is the
top right graph and bottom right
graph the top right graph what  that
runs what it collects is the
megabytes per second group that is
entering the database as you can see they are
numbers around 600 mb per
second it has dropped a little more now because
both in 600 megabytes per second on
a basis of  data of 25 terabytes
then summarizing clau de spanair is
a relational database that is to say
multi-region sql because it is supported in
all in multiple johnny
distributed throughout all continents
transactional with strong consistency and
that allows
practically unlimited scalability infinite and with
this then I give way to israel to
continue with the session thank you
very much to rafa and robert kubica
because it seems impressive to me that in an
event like this we do  s live demos of
this style to have 9 clusters of
governors working to make
fans up to the rhythm I find it very
funny
as you have seen this is tested it is
proven that it works within google
we use it in a lot of products
and you have it since the 16th of  May
available to use it, we already have
some clients in Spain who have
started to use it and I encourage you to
start testing it,
but
indeed a part of the databases,
but there is another very important part,
which is the following, which is the whole issue
of data  warehousing and we have
more and more data, you have data from the points of
sale, customer data from
machine complaints, each time
we are, we have gone from there being no
data here, there is a lot of data and one
of the problems is when there is a
lot of data is to have  the
correct tools to exploit
bit queries is the service we offer
from google to build these data
warehouses and p  To be able to scale in this
sea of data that you are here, we ha
e all of you in your compa
ies and google as well, as you can imagi
e, big query is a
ool that allows you to launch queri
s from gb to petabytes, worki
g in seconds and alway
answering this in seconds  It is quite
spectacular because it is not necessary to
size the machines, the storage,
define how I want the
architecture to be, what does the cluster have to look like,
you simply upload the
data, continue adding data and
execute which does not matter if
you are doing an analysis
and 200  Analysts, we are going to
take care of the scalability behind the scenes
so that it can scale to everything
you may need,
and the objective with bit query is to
democratize access to data
warehousing and access to
data analytics,
but of course you also know this, as do I.
One of the first problems you
encounter in any
data warehouse project is t  have the
correct data
if you do not have the correct data in the
warehouse what ends up happening to you is that
you are taking a biased photo and the
analysis you do is not the right one
so systems are needed to be
able to put all the data inside my
leather to  that we have created data
transfer data transfer we have launched it
first with our own
adwords products the click youtube and from there
you will be able to transfer the data that
you have within those systems in
a very simple way but we
are also working with many and sv and with
a  lots of partners to take us the
data from wherever they want to bi query
behind me you have the list to me it
seems spectacular I'm sure that
any of the tools should and
that you have or that you have recently proposed
works with bit query and it's
not just the tools  it should and there are
also many tl tools and
also more and more
software-as-a-service cloud systems
but of course it is not  only that there is and sv
is that they do the integration but
we also need partners that
do the implementation the last mile
the last kilometer is worth
here you have the list of the Spaniards
who are in the Spanish breaks who
are working with us to
help us to do  integration to
help us integrate bit
query and the TV systems you
have today
but it's not just bit query and it's not
just spanair when we talk about big
data you tell us about problems or projects or
needs and what we do from
google is  Trying to solve these
challenges that it poses to us is the first is
the cloud data warehouse that
we have already talked about, but the second that we
have encountered more many times from
clients who have carried out big data projects by
setting up Hadoop clusters or
Spark clusters.  and we all know how
difficult it is to manage an
esparto cluster stop updating the versions
the security of the operating system  or the
secret is a mess
that we offer you data pro is a cluster
100% managed by google where
we take care of the entire stack
and what you can do is
use what also comes with data because
a new paradigm that are the clusters
of '  use and throw' you create the cluster do
the calculations that you have to do the
fairy strings that you have to do
the word processes the ones that you have
to do and throw it away you don't keep the
cluster launched and working or
resize it just because you feel like it  you
use it and throw it away and lastly
real-time analytics more and more
we see in the gaming
industry in the advertising industry and even
in some reservation industries
real-time analytics of what
the user is doing to  That is why we
need to have input mechanisms
in real time, since the one we offer
from Google that allows us to carry
out the entire process
of data transformation necessary with data flow and from there.  From
there, put it in the virtual database
and to be able to port it later or in the
system that you want,
what we are telling you today is an
end-to-end solution in the management of
your world on your
of your workloads related
to  data management is not just
a database from google we
offer you tools to be able
to manage your data as
we do in google from real time
to data warehouse queries
but analysts I was one of the first
analysts have a
fundamental limitation  and it is that you can analyze a
quantity of information and manage a
volume of information but when
we are talking about explosions and
large volumes of data we need to
take the next step and from google
we want to help you in the next wave
which is machine learning 3 or artificial
intelligence first  what does this mean
that from google we are going to continue
investing in projects like tensor
flow d  where we have made a great effort
to convert the tools
that we used internally into an
open source project and share it with
the community so that you can carry out
your machine learning
and artificial intelligence projects and we are
also making the products
on which they carried  then their models
once you have trained the
prediction models and the artificial
intelligence models that you have a site to be
able to execute it for that we have launched
cloud machine learning where
you have to worry about the cpu gpu
and cpu or what we are using for
behind whether we are using one or 50
or 5,000 machines
to carry out the training process and you will also be able to
find a place where you can exploit
your models once they are
trained, of course you can download
the model as a prize and if you want to
use it locally  of course you can
put the models inside mobile applications
iles that it is one of the things
that we have been working on more
lately with snapdragon and other
chip manufacturers and our goal
is that you can use the
models wherever you want
but we must recognize that machine
learning artificial intelligence is
a challenge is a challenge  for companies like
google, bbv, bq, big
technology companies, but what
we also want is to offer solutions
so that you can put machine learning and
artificial intelligence in your
applications without having all
that technical knowledge, we do that with
what would come to be like  a kind of
smart switch that our
apis are and that allow us to give you access to
all our models in training with
that you will be able to do things like
understand speech
understand what is happening in
images or
videos translate anything
practically anything  language
today I come to talk to you about two that
I think are the most interesting  because it is in
the last ones that we have news that
are visions and video ep there are visions that
there are in the first place it has been very
interesting this last year because we have
achieved you have sent us so that
we have more or less 1500 million
images it has been a resounding success and
We have listened very clearly to what he
told us and how we could improve it and
we have followed the feedback that
has reached us from companies like you,
companies such as platinum and ds
that use it to enrich their
content management or
real estate agencies that use it to
find the
most suitable house for a client or
e-commerce systems to make
recommendations and listening to all that
feedback we have made in the next the
next block of improvements that
you have right now in beta available
which is a greater integration within the
northeast graph all the  labels and
brands that we recognize are better more
similar well they are exactly the
same as those of  google.com in the email
search and there we have enriched them with a
lot of the feedback you have given us and
then also the whole part of lozère
january cr we have improved until we can
reuse them in systems such as invoices
or large volumes of content which
was one of the points  that until now
we had to improve besides that, well,
you can imagine if you are able to
recognize a photo if you do it at 60
frames per second
you are able to recognize videos you can
also imagine that this is a problem
of scale it is not the same to do the
recognition  in one where at 60 photos
per second
the video is a very interesting business content
yes it is true that what is
most in videos are kittens from youtube we
have to recognize them we have it is
what occupies the most storage but well it
is also a very commercial content
interesting and we are sure that
building there are solutions on top of the
very interesting video pencil but
again more than just telling you what I think  the
best thing is that rafa shows it to us and that
you can see the demo lab demo does it have videos
of kittens or not it's not there but it's a
google home demo google video
although I know you also like it let's
see the video
[Music]
[  Applause]
fernando
yes
[Music]
me
delighted to meet you
yes
[Music]
well I have put this video for you because
the videos are the videos that we have in a
file and on which we execute the
intel video and in drought and  as
israel the seer has commented before, the ine is
sent is a new machine
learning service from google and what it does
precisely is to find out the content
that is inside that video and it
returns the labels and the moment in
time where it has found all
the elements that are part of that
video within the frames
then you have noticed throughout the
video because a dog a
birthday cake a garage a car appeared
so if we upload this video
to the  video intelligence ceip and there is what it
returns to us is precisely the
content that we see there on the screen to
the left the labels say the
elements that it recognizes within the video
and to the right the timeline that is to say the
moment second minute where
each one of them has been found  those elements
then, for example, in the case of the
dog, if we click here, we would see
exactly the moment in the video where
the dog appears and, well, a garage, a
birthday cake, etc., it would still put us
exactly where he saw that moment in the
video, so this is with a  video but
the interesting thing about the seer line sep and
there is being able to apply this to an
archive of videos that you may have
imagine that you are a
television media company or a security company
that has a huge number of videos
of several terabytes this allows you to do
allows to classify the videos allows to
classify classify the content of
these videos and search them search for them by
content  imagine, for example, that
I really like the beach, I want to
search this archive of videos that I have for
anyone that has a frame of a
beach and they are already long videos, they are videos that are
over an hour long, some
of them simply looking for bits of me
it will reply with the videos
in my file that they have at some
point in time they have a beach inside
so for example they have told me
this video of barcelona and they
also reply with the exact moment where
the beach appears then and click on
me for example  here, well, it would appear
just like a beach or another moment in
time where they found it, this one
here that finds it for me too,
then this is the video intelligence it
sends and it is basic to
apply to the video what
our maxim learning services
previously applied in the case  of the spy and
for text or in the case of the vision of
foot for images now applied for
videos managed service and service
that conti  It is continually improving because they
are models trained by google that
we continually improve,
so over time the accuracy of the
elements they find will
improve back to the word israel there
were no kittens israel but at least there
was google home and another series  of things
thank you very much
well thank you very much rafa slam and
welcome
mayer again
hello good morning
the version is the sui extensive version
of names right the great late for the
caller the jesuita in westin del 46 jones in
force with act collaborate / the next
big al  day the name
to keep playing the actor again of
being on cold from the one generated by
saint barts
in the annex of the day
[Music]
grace jones poor city of sentences
for letting them come to say phrases
of the 29 days in city and university
cage  john sawyers fuhrimann
embracing sometimes
[Music]
companies our servers güiza
players in many songs
axel also james dean wright his name  e
one
is people from the region just be and syntax
isidro fainé in live and chevron anfac
google drive
place
in the video
drive finally take certain hours
in expansion
or
in 505 it is possible formula of the tenor gary
own video
next
name
report
this new project
66 of this law
i
scolari
efe
drive
find out stable and solid behring in
great social
m
great
witty
i
would see me
and
[Music]
and indeed in the chin grounds there is
no enmity between the attack for
sale to a happy guy
etc
[Music]
in the middle of the night of bollywood you
hurry just like the request for changes
to encourage gameplay weiner
current victims of jennifer friend and sensitive away
you know they are going to hit me mex javi casares
where he rode for your years he must sell
greg lemond miguel
[Music]
and
oh
[Music]
of the problems
team
in the email
m
information and science is so enormous
that the floor of activity is degraded
yesterday is the wind i  n the market
he describes himself from the network is to
transform the city he believes in
hectares when the calves ideas of
truth is to destroy phrases in the
process it is clear the extinction
connect solid enclave of an ex is
elected brinton ex speaker and virginia
put the  french is very commercial
in the statement find out underworld
evolution thousands of benefit and security touch
[Music]
tomorrow
match effect good morning to all
virginia mateos director of marketing and
communication of gss group and they have given me
five minutes to tell you about our
experience with  ti suite so I am going to
go very quickly today in gss group to
put them in context we are an
omni channel customer relationship management company
or in other words a contact
center we in gss group are very
curious and we are always in
search of technology  it is a
business model that allows us to generate
productivity is to increase productivity
is and we are always looking for
c  Constantly then we wanted to make an
organizational change and make a
more collaborative environment that would allow us to
do things in real time and we began to
investigate among the different
solutions that were on the market
we began to talk with google and the
first thing that caught our attention from
suite was  that it was a very
simple, very intuitive, very easy-to-use solution
that was not going to have many
usage problems at the company level, to which we add
that
compared to what we already had in the
company, it had the same and many more
applications,
so we continued to continue the
conversation with google and we said having
google behind it as a brand is also
good, not just because it's google and
everything we know, but because we saw
that what they have is a
very strong spirit of innovation and a very
fast and adaptability to
needs.  fast is to say that
anything that is detected in
the jesuit suite that is not yet very
adapted to the user  that has functionality failures,
you already know that Google
has a team behind it working to
develop some new update
that is going to remedy that issue, as
you have been seeing in fact in the
presentations this morning
with all this if we also add all
the issues of  security that it offered and of
course the ingredient of the price
that is not important also because
we decided to start working with
jit suite what we did was
start with the implementation of 2200
licenses we in gss group are
100 employees globally and
we started  we arrived with 25 percent
of the global plan of one hundred percent of
the global plan that we want to have in
three months we have implemented these
2,200 licenses but they have been three
months not of total implementation but
first of technological implementation with
this purest technological trainer  and
then really implementation at the
business level of establishing
work models that  really generate
efficiencies because maybe a month and a
half and the results are being very
positive we have a very high level of
adoption and we begin to
detect important benefits efficiencies
for the company what we wanted to
achieve we started instead of the whole
company by three more
familiar departments that are the ones that we started
to get involved in this whole issue with google,
which were the IT and
commercial and marketing department that I represent
and that to do all the tests to
make sure that everything will work well and
that it won't  there was no mistake and then
extrapolate it to what is our core
business, which is the call center, the
most notable efficiencies there are many but
the most significant ones that I can
tell you about what they have generated for us are
time savings and productivity
is well  all the documentary agility that
was being commented was commenting
bill
with the intelligence of google that
locates the documents of a m
super fast way according to the
usability that you use the most the one that you use the least
is that really in your suite it is
impossible not to get where
you want to go or to find a
document create a document found
a document can be done in up to
five different ways that  it is impossible
not to get there the whole topic of
assigning tasks from the same documents
from any document you can assign
tasks solve tasks which saves a
lot of time a lot of minutes of
time in email management in remote work
we have been able to create
a document repository  that we
could not do before in real time
with a beastly knowledge management
for the company that allows access
to documents in a super
fast way and on top of that they are updated
updated forgive in real time
the issue of generating sayyed sayyed
for products sites for events  sites
for reports of our clients
any the  company can do it,
the use of technologies has been liberalized
without having
specific technological knowledge and well, the issue
of reports for us is really
fundamental
for our business, it is super
important, the globality that we have
gained as a company has been fundamental
not only because of the hangout but  the issue of
videoconferences but because
the barrier of speaking directly with the
other side in Peru
has been broken, and we have already broken the barrier,
one-on-one conversations, not only by
videoconference but by chat,
communication has increased a lot
in our  company and has generated
many deficiencies transparency
we have jumped on the
collaboration train and at the beginning it was a bit of
a barrier to entry and
now every time we all want to share more
if we are getting
into that line a lot and it generates a
lot of  deficiencies at the
company level and last but not
least the security  authority for many
reasons but above all also for the
issue of being able to have a
constant traceability of the information and knowing that we will
be able to detect in the event of
a massive leak of information
that is essential for our business
five minutes we have finished
thank you very much  I hope it helps
see you in eps
[Applause]
uy
why don't you need is the world web
product support in 20 brand new open
extend the sedena I'm going to sell what I
don't take care of it in good god my way
price 6 in having  it's frank pearl on the
spiral network trail speaker his
verbal attack
in my opinion don't think this team
am
one of the things it does is different from
google is our commitment to
open systems and you can understand
open systems like opensource and it's
true open  source is one of them but
open systems
means in general being flexible
means giving back control to
users means giving the tools
so that the  user can decide how and
when it is deployed on a
certain platform
in the origins of the internet in an
open system in itself in 1974 the
windsurfing and volcano paper at no time
remained with intellectual property and it
is not paid today it is not paid
today royalties for the fact of using
tcp/ip
and at google we believe that this type of
approach is the approach of saying well my
system is going to be open my system is not
going to retain the user is that what
facilitates innovation and  that is what
made tcp/ip the standard that i am that is
what made the internet possible
at google we have more than 10 years of
experience sharing open source code
and if we are talking about
open systems as well as open source systems
we have collaborated on both
systems and  pay son linux git
today last year only last year
almost 300,000 with different
committees in open source projects we are
talking about 700 comics a day
by 15.0  00 google this is the
approach that makes google one of the
main providers of thinking today
and one of those one of those collaborations
one of those contributions that we have
made to the open source world has been the
contribution of see groups to the kernel of
linux easy groups is the cornerstone
that has made all
container technology possible today if groups
is what we use in google
when deploying systems that are
independent of the platform on
which they run is what makes it possible
deploying a platform and services
that is scalable and that is agile at the same
time is what portable containers do
and without clubs what it does is
continue and contain contain the
content of that application that you want to
deploy making it safe but
doing the same time
lightweight containers by
themselves are not deployable when
making our own applications they
need an extra step that would be
container orchestration and that is
where dq vernet is the one that is the
de facto standard today for
container orchestration.
zero as an open source platform and
open to the public cooper net is
tremendous attraction to be contributed by
continuing night live
to the cloud computing foundation
and that is what has made it possible for a
lot of platforms to have taken a
run on this platform
today  today in more than 4000 open
source projects running on the basis of
governors and this and these numbers that
can be seen on the screen continue to
grow the platform continues to grow
and that is the idea of keeping open
ystems the idea of saying what works well
n google for  to make it
adaptable to the rest of the world it has to
be open source it has to be open
and that way each person can
incorporating its different pieces into a
platform that is a stable component
cornet is to a certain extent the promise
of containers taken to the next
level to be able to deploy a platform and
decide well, I want to work
with this particular cloud provider
not to have any type of login
I want to deploy  today in google cloud
tomorrow I want to deploy in another
cloud platform or I want to deploy in
my own data center to a man and
you can decide in the end where he wants to
deploy without the need to make
modifications to your platform
which is actually the dream of the box
el  next step there was a
collaboration between google ibm and leaf that
allows deploying applications based
on microservices developing the
next level that can be deployed
on cooper net today and
later on other platforms
such as cloud foundry and the idea is to be
able to solve  all the connection part
between microservices to secure these
micro  services monitoring reporting
etc. etc.
if we are talking about containers, it is
the containers that are doing
today the extra step so that penn is
flexible penn is inflexible in bar mind
is jay and can be deployed in
europe from this year the rock  inflexible
however mind expands the number of
platforms that can be deployed
on a slope in such a way that
seven platforms can be deployed java
page and country are go of course but
also platforms like ruby platforms like
igning don't hate box cars but anyth
ng you can  encapsulate in
a docker container can be deployed
on penn inflexible though so you
can bring your own platform with your
own development stack your own
your own
libraries sometimes being an open platform
means being able to deploy
non-open systems that
we believe in  that it doesn't have to be only
possible to deploy platforms like
windows it has to be the m  best
platform where you can deploy
windows systems and for that today
you can deploy systems based on
windows 2008 2012 2016 you can
deploy platforms based on
writing server 2012 2014 2016 again
but also extensions on visual
studio that allow you to deploy on the
platform  from google cloud from the
development environment itself or command
letts for power shell to be able to
work with yecla or from powershell
with command line autocomplete
the idea is to try to make it
develop on windows in the same
way that other teams develop
on linux  with the same ease of
development with the same non-fixed
flexes
as new additions to this
environment it is currently possible to deploy
Esquivel server enterprise with the
possibility of high availability with the
possibility of deploying line class in
Google Cloud systems based
on Punto Network can be deployed on
appendini se  can unfold  about
container engine and also for clients
who want to rely on a partner that
values the deployment we have the w
ndows migration partners program partn
rs that can support compa
ies to deploy their windo
s systems in google cloud not the same facil
tating the options for the diffe
ent clients a cha
ge  which is going to be introduced in the
third quarter of this year
in trip is a change
our support model our support model used to
be based on silver gold and silver
gold platinum but we have found
that environment is not
flexible enough because our needs for
support changes throughout the year where
a given project the phases
a project goes through change and a
project can be a development phase,
production or even with gemma and
the new support model of
engineer and engineer support establishes a
more personal relationship  between the
development teams and the support team
within google clo  You in such a way that
in that law that you are going to receive and the type
of support that you are going to receive is
different depending on what your
needs are because maybe you need
a much faster response time,
which we will introduce in the third
quarter of this  year we will be talking about
a support system for development
engineer and engineer support in jr for
development for production and for Angol
in a world in which 45 percent
of the expenditure made in the cloud is
not really used, it can be
because the machines are already fixed for you,
this is the certain size that
your machine has but it could also
be because you are reserving a
machine for three years and they reserved
complicated machines because you do not know
in six months what you are going to
need  if they tell you in three
years you are going to need this machine
in three years what is really difficult is
knowing you know what your need is
today but you don't know what  What is going to
happen next year
adding to this
hourly billing the fact that all of us
pay for what we consume in the cloud
we are all interested neither auto
scale auto scale at night
auto charge on weekends auto
climb during the holidays we want to
stop paying for these machines to be
able to pay later chair for
more machines every day and we lift
machines every day that
is billed by the minute because it is billed by the hour it
makes a difference
at google we work from different
initiatives to try to avoid  This is
to try to change this way
of understanding the cloud and one of
them is well known, which is our
sustained discounts. The fact
that over a month, the longer
a machine is working, the cheaper it
comes out with an accumulated discount that
can arrive.  to 30 percent for a
machine that is running
all the time and if that machine for
any  reason it stops and then
picks up again those periods of
time are concatenated to give the best
possible discount at the end of the month we have
calculated the average discount
that our customers have in the
google cloud we are talking about a 24
percent discount that  that you have is
on average without the need to do anything
simply by using the system this
is what we are going to do to
facilitate to lower the cost of the
final invoice
we speak of a system based on
flexibility and flexibility also
means if a defined medal supplier
is the  size of virtual machine
that I can use that limits me
because 12.48 cpu 1632 cpu's 64 or cpu
powers of 2 means that we double the
cost every time we go from one model
of machine to the next the
cost doubles and it is possible that I am
interested in  48 cpu's what about that
need and what we do in web cloud
is we don't believe in
default settings we believe in  the possibility
that each person can specify their
own amount of their own amount of
memory and can specify exactly
what they want to use
calculating average what is saved
in google cloud using
custom configurations we are
talking 19% savings but it used to be
the case that there was a man with a
ratio between cpu and memory with two
cpu you can get this certain
amount of maximum memory with 8 sep is
you have this amount of maximum
memory last week we have eliminated
that chip in google cloud and youtube memory
gration a  today if someone wants to
build a machine with two cpu if 455
gigabytes of memory they can perfectly
do it
brightside singh we understand that it
is possible to know exactly what
needs they have in your machine at the
moment you are working on the
project but later you forget
of the system you look at the following
pay attention to the next project
you will have in the google console a notice
of the machines that can eliminate cpu
that can eliminate memory to
lower the cost of that particular
machine and it is because we understand that not
everyone can keep an eye
on the systems that are already in
the past  because you are focused on the
next project and that is what
we take care of automatically
we have mentioned before the billing
per minute of the fact that day by day
weekend weekend it is
interesting those machines that are
stopping to bill per minute with  a
minimum of 10 minutes which is also
interesting for before we talked about
data pro clusters you already had a park
you created for the need you have at
that moment the billing per minute
also your mail
and finally
just discount committee discounts for
for companies that know which one is going to  be your
baseline of resources, I know exactly
what machines I am going to need
throughout the year at a minimum,
because I can  want hey I want to
get the lowest possible discount
up to 57 percent discount on
these machines that I know will be my
minimum possible but when we talked about
this and before we were saying I don't know
what machine it is exactly I'm going to
want so that the reservation  of resources that
can be done in google cloud is per
cpu yes memory you do not pay for a
certain machine you say I want
12 cpu's this amount of gigabytes of
memory and I will use them as I
see fit and that is the idea of
n system  that is the idea of a flexi
le system giving back control to the user
f how I deploy we ha
e talked about different ways
f accumulating these discounts we ha
e talked about susta
ned discounts for doing raid sightseeing we ha
e talked about it is also the diffe
ence in starting price in  the
cloud compared with other
providers is all this what
the google cloud can be up to
60% cheaper
and yes  we are talking about the next step in
google we understand that everyone
comes with a history not everyone
can afford to deploy in a single
cloud and this hybrid cloud exists for that
perfectly reasonable and normal to say
look I have a system man and I
am not going to abandon it  and it is normal or I am
already deploying in another cloud provider
and it is also normal but today
is the perfect day to experiment and
to look for the next the next
step
when I finish this keynote out there
we will be the google experts they will be
our partners  so
let's stop talking let's talk about what the next
project could be what could be the proof of
concept to start experimenting with
all this to find more
flexibility in the platform we
work with because we understand that being
tied to a certain
cloud provider is not  the way to facilitate
innovation
and with this I would like to give way to the
next speaker sergio álvarez is the
chief  cartoon product officer a
leading company in innovation in spain
welcome
[Applause]
well thank you very much to google for giving us
the opportunity to tell you a little about
what we do and for
letting us participate in this event that
looks excellent for
tell you a little about what we do instead
of continuing to talk about the future, which is one
of the things that is going to happen the most
during the event, I am going to talk a
little about the past, the map you see
on the screen is what we could
consider almost the first
niche model but made in a completely
analogical way this map was made by alexander
von humboldt an explorer around
1800 and what he did was save data
during his ascent to chimborazo
save data on at what altitude and with what
soil characteristics
the different  species thanks to this
information that he collected in his
activities towards the creation of a model that
could project all the mountains of
a  america
if that could be done by a good 1800
imagine what we can do now
now for the first time it is true that everything
happens somewhere the digitization
of space with nanosatellites the
digitization of the sky with drones
the digitization of cities the
internet of things  the digitization of
the streets of the people how many
here do not have an android or the
digitization even of the coffee machines
that tell us when we are
making a coffee is what is doing
that now, as I was saying, everything happens
somewhere what happens is  that 80% of
this information that is generated today on the
internet has a reference to where it
happens, it has a reference to a place,
but only 10% of this data is currently being
used in companies
to make better decisions and that is where
so it is born carto imagine the
size of the opportunity for example the
new york city hall- the new york city hall today has
access to a tool  through
which you can see different indicators
hundreds of indicators in the city about
how things are going how many
bike accidents there have been how many
calls to the assistance service
how many lampposts or how much crime there is in
different areas what is the rate of
cleanliness the rate of filling  of their
containers,
apart from doing a very
simple
geospatial analysis, telecommunications companies
use all-spatial analysis and
use cardboard to know where to
deploy more infrastructure to
improve their service offerings to
calculate their potential market, etc., or
financial entities, we proudly
share one  of these customers with
google 9 es viver tries to measure or measures
the economic temperature of cities
allows us to allow retailers to
tell them how to optimize their businesses
based on where the different
transactions take place based on how
the economy moves allows cities to
understand  the economic impact  ico of some
of the largest events or
also allows these same cities to understand
the behavior patterns of their
population based on consumption patterns
we have been analyzing the data for years and
looking at the postal codes and if those
postal codes no longer tell us  nothing
these are questions that we try to
solve fourth today it has
more than 1100 clients in 65 countries
among which we even find
google which uses our technology
to do data analysis especially
in google trends
these 65 clients are doing this
analysis or these excuse 1,100 clients
are doing this analysis of the
data as I said from the geospatial point of view
which leads us to a
certain technical complexity and certain and
certain particularities in
the end the first law of geography
says everything is related to everything but
the closest things to each other are
more related than the most distant and it
is from the beginning  ipio on which
we rely
for this things that we do in song and
things with which those of us who trust
google do not process more than 1
billion
dynamic requests per month cardboard also
has to be an open platform
on 80 of the  technology that we want open
source I invite you to come by because
our repositories all this
technology is deployed in different
clouds in the google cloud we have a
clear one in Europe and a cloud in
North America also google maps is perhaps
the best known map product in the
world  customers who already use
google maps to view their
information who already use google maps
to find out how to get from one place to
another do not have to abandon it, they can
continue to use
google services within cartoon out of the box
and lastly every time we generate  more
data and more data and imply new
systems to store them and new
systems to analyze them shortly we will
announce the connection to  google vic
query to be able to access large
amounts of geospatial information and to be
able to carry out analysis
at a magnitude level
that were practically impossible until then,
and with this we
reiterate our gratitude to google
for allowing us to participate and thank you very much
[  Applause]
Yes, hello, good morning everyone, once again
we have reached the last presentation of
this plenary session, what is the level
of energy like? Well, I would like
to take the opportunity to thank all the
speakers who have participated so far,
the truth is that it is impressive, especially
our  customers who are in the end the ones
who rule and the ones who make us want
to continue growing and doing it
better and better, google has a room with a
view to becoming one of
your strategic partners and with
our products and services to help
you make anything come true
may your dreams be in this new digital world
we have to improve our products  ucts
we have to grow in infrastructure
we have to be much closer to
all of you as we have mentioned but I
already said this morning we will not
achieve it without the help of our
partners
we have started the morning like this and we are going to
finish this first session
talking precisely about  partners and for
this what I would like is to call three
of our partners who are going to count
on us and who are going to see us or are going to
share with you what their
strategic approaches are towards the
cloud and towards the cloud specifically of
google cloud me  I would like to call
Alberto García, who is responsible for
Cloud First at Accenture, Nacho Velilla,
who is Director of Cloud +, and Gonzalo
de la Vega, who is General Manager for
Europe at Fast lic, please give them a round of applause,
well, I think the session is
going to be entertaining, let's  a lot of speed but I think that
the cloud is a bit like that too and in this
last session what I would like is
for us to share  iera jce well then as
you see it no then if you think it's okay I
'll ask each of you a few questions starting
with you and alberto no cloud first
accenture has developed a clear
cloud strategy you've been using it for
some time and specifically a commitment
to google cloud  can you
briefly tell us what this bet consists of
yes thanks isaac well first of all
thank you and the whole team for this
event and for being here the truth
is that it is an honor and a pleasure and
also see how this is growing the
truth is  fantastic as you say
we almost two years ago and
we made a first investment in a
company called cloud sherpas
which was the largest integrator
of cloud solutions developer at a level at a
level
and at the same time we started to
assemble our team here  in
Spain since then, well now
we already have about 1400 people with
certifications in Google products and
we are also developing d  different
solutions solutions to transform
the current architecture of companies to
the google cloud us very very
specific solutions that are really allowing us to
do things totally
different from what we
used to do before and well our vision a little
you asked me why we are doing
all  these investments also in
skills and talent
because we really see that this is
very different from what we could do
with private cloud with
automated environments let's say on premise it
has nothing to do with the level of
innovation and the agility with which
we are building  applications, for
example, we are making a lot
of call center transformations with
google technology and before we began to
have releases and versions of these
new channels of these new
interactions in 3, 4 or 5 months, now
google in 67 weeks we begin to have
solutions that are gradually improving
and transforming  in this
example los call c  enters using
your technology is very
interesting
I think that of course we all have it clear they
have many facets there are many
components that are necessary to be a
cloud-type solution when you think of
google and when you think of the
google cloud what are those aspects that
you think of  they provide more value and more
innovation more differentiation us
the truth is that in google
we started with the whole topic of
big data data and that is where we see a
clear difference with any other solution when
we talk about handling information with a
lot of volume and with high performance
well then  we have a
reference solution which is all the
big data platforms bit data query
google analytics studies
the second issue we are
discovering I would say in the last
six months is the trained models
that our team has been talking about before,
which are  those speech models of
yours
of vision natural language recognition  up and that they are
allowing us not to have to
do it on the other hand, but it is
good not to always have to train
our models, which in the end is what
is costing us a lot of work,
having trained models, which is on
top of that, they continuously improve until
our applications  they are differential
and the last issue that we are also
seeing that is differential and in
which we are testing is the whole issue of
migration of loads existing loads in
the gas ones if not the leaf and seafood what
is as it is in the systems
I'm taking it to Google's cloud computing
and what we're seeing are therefore
first-time savings of around 30
% theses and when we already begin to
adapt the systems and operations to
the capabilities that it has from
automation
to computing  from google well we got
to 50 60 percent let's say in your
savings savings tc or
great alberto thank you very much for sharing
a little s  about your vision and about
your strategies and thanks to
accenture for the support you are giving us it
is a pleasure
nacho
very good and taconic a company with an
impeccable track record in the world of
data centers as a commitment to the cloud
well I think there would be  I have to
start by saying that
klaus más
is part of the end of the main
infrastructure and tea supplier in the
Iberian Peninsula, which is iconic, but
thanks to being its professional services division,
we have managed to create a
complete portfolio of infrastructures and
we no longer only talk about our data
centers but we are
also talking about the public cloud or
hybrid solutions and the thing is that I think
the world is changing you a lot
because an example as you were right
now more or less is that five years ago
they asked you if you think that a
datacenter company was going to be here as one
of the main partners of
google that all of us who
are here would have thought  in this forum it is something strange it would
be that in the face of new needs I think
that new solutions have to be found there and
it is no longer a question of whether I leave
my data center
if I take the entire public cloud I
think that hybridization will probably go
to be one of the solutions that will
be adopted the most in the future and the relationship
between the world of the data center and the world of the
cloud, because today I think they
are great allies, the club has
brought us things like
hyperconnectivity, access  to new technologies
[Music]
and the ubiquity of data, but all of this
without a data center network that gives you
sufficient capillarity, of course
you won't be able to achieve it. Congratulations on
that flexibility that I think has
to characterize the way of acting today
in  day for any company and
obviously also for
you according to your experience what
are the first steps that you advise
a company to take its first
steps in the cloud to say the least  ration
good good question well let's see here
the first thing you have to ask is
why you want to go to the cloud
probably until very recently the
main driver to make the decision
was a purely economic issue in the end
you think the cloud is going to be
cheaper but I think that today
the main thing in all of this is that
companies want to do
things differently, they want to transform how they
are doing everything and in this the key
I think is knowing where you are and where
you want to go and analyze  very well
what are your systems your applications
understand that it will work better in the
public cloud that it will work
within the fta center because today it
is not portable to the cloud and where
hybrid solutions can bring you a
lot of value and mark that
very clear roadmap to try to get out of the
minimum because if not in the end
you always have problems and follow
this line the cloud in the end has
brought us what it said has brought me
closer  many technologies that previously
needed thousands or millions of euros
even to be able to test them and that were
only accessible to very large
companies and today even the smallest
startup is capable of starting to do
impressive things within the cloud
thanks for those brief but important
tips one last question  and being a
little more specific, what is your
commitment or what does your commitment consist of
in supporting google cloud,
well, cloud marc we consider ourselves
a very lively company that tries to
innovate and I think that when talking about
this type of thing, thinking of google was
So, it is obligatory for us, the people of
Paraná, with you that when
the mind of Google ends,
the first thing you think of is a
super innovative company with a
technological solvency that very few have in the
market, because I think it was more than
necessary than us  were we here
I think no one doubts that the world is going to
be multi-platform and multi-provided  dor and
in this google within the hyper
scale has a lot to offer and not
only is it capable of covering most of
the client's needs at the
infrastructure level within the cloud but
you even really have
very innovative solutions with great performance
and here we have talked before about
that we have heard about
data flow bit query app engine are things that
really work well I can
give you an example of a
digital marketing company with which we are
working and we have made an
architecture in google cloud in  the one that
with the part of google pop psuv we are
collecting more than 10 thousand web impressions
per second and with data it was flow and big
wedding they are doing the analysis in
real time when this used to
take around six hours to do
what I think  that it is a clear bet
in which we have started and that we must
continue building the perfect path together,
thanks again for
sharing that is  e magnificent example and
thank you for your partnership and
last but not least
gonzalo Fácil and I am sure if the
entire audience knows who is easy because you
don't tell us in 30 seconds who
is easy and I will tell it easier and it turns out to
be very  fast it's a fact cloud platform
then if it actually defines
itself by what it's called edge it's the edge
of a cloud of the cloud and it's a
platform on which
value-added services are offered in that
delivery layer like the edge  of the cloud where
you can deliver content
safely, where you can balance the
traffic that reaches you, both well-
intentioned and malicious traffic, and
where you can add a layer of logic
and process all the magic that happens at
the origins, which is where the
applications live and  you can apply this
logic from the
notification process to edge computing
a thousand other things that we make
points very easy and that if I had
to  highlighting perhaps two things that make it
different is everything in real time,
both when managing a cache
and when pushing a
configuration when it comes to acting, doing
your things or when customers
interact how much the application is all in
real time  and perhaps the other thing is that they are
extremely elastic-minded we
allow people to program
we believe in boxers we
are very geek people and we allow you to
build your own applications you
don't have to call anyone it could be because of
your configuration and play with our  network
is a platform perhaps like you
we make available the
intelligent agent that we have been seeing
speak here this morning the people of
there are map applications etc why they
want marvelous solutions
stupendous two really
magical words not real time and elasticity that
I think everyone  we want for our
systems and for our and for our
businesses according to what your experience is
experience with the cloud and as
you see the cloud market in this
type of field, well, our
experience with the cloud goes very
hand in hand with you, which is
wonderful, I don't think it's easy and I,
in particular, are nobody to say
where is the market going to be but if
we see clear trends in technology
and what we see is a growing symbiosis
between the
origin infrastructure where people store their
applications and where they create using the
cloud and that layer of acceleration and
logic that there is  between the origin and the
end user then we see how what
used to be several layers in the end
becomes a single layer and how they
get closer we have for those
who do not know we are interconnected
google is easy and in many
points of the planet  where we have a
presence through physical fiber cables
that unplug if nobody stumbles, they
allow working with
you with us to be a single
platform and I think that's where it is  Where does
the cloud go? Well, it is one thing. I think
we have said it here today.
My colleagues at accenture have said it. It
is not an optional question anymore, nor is it a
question either, as I said before,
economics, it is already a question of  what it
allows you to build and the things you
can do to focus on what
really matters  of traffic or if there is a
network topology problem if you have
to worry about the music working it
will be great and they have the best
catalog and I think that you and us
but all of us here
allow a little bit of it to occur to
people to  focus on his own and can give
free rein to creativity the creativity
they said I saw what nacho coloma said
when doing interesting things
great yesterday I shared myself like this on
our website it is quite p  pay
attention you work with consuming two thousand
clients these dogs of our
website hundreds of thousands of clients from
different industries not from ecommerce
online publishing travel
what benefits does google cloud bring to
these industries
I can speak from the point of view
of the clients in which we are
together and the solution that we have created
together google cloud and easy and I think that
the most important thing and one thing that we have
in common is that the google
cloud platform allows I repeat these are things that
we have seen something in the morning and that
I suppose we will continue to see
throughout today but it is a platform
that allows you to create that allows you to really
focus on your creative process, whether it is
an application of a service of a
video that you want to put on or it allows
you to really focus on how you design it
and what it is that you  you want to achieve and
how you are going to relate to your
users and allows you not to have to
worry about managing the
od databases  the garden or low-
level things both at the level of origin and at the
level of the etx layer and simply
focus really give free rein wind
unleash creativity great
and to conclude and finally can
you tell us about a specific example
that you  seems especially
representative
I would love there are several we could
talk about vimeo we could talk about
weeks we could talk about cart
in the newspaper but I would like to talk
about spotify I like music a lot
I like slayer specifically and in this
case
if you think it's all  music for
all users this is what the
founder of mr spotify what's-his-
name had in mind when he created it
then where all the music is saved
to all the metadata of the file the
covers all the information of the
artists and information of the  users
of their transactions of their profiles their
recommendations all that magic is created
on your platform and when it comes to
reaching all users  users on their
devices wherever they are on the
planet with
unpredictable traffic patterns with spikes with
drops with drops with all kinds of this
is a bit of what we do
together allow all music to be
available to all users
through  a tremendously powerful origin infrastructure
and data
processing that
you provide and this edge layer of logic
that we bring this kind of
veneer that we put over the
magic that jce enables you I like to
think that we allow people to do
magic is  perfect what a beautiful word
gonzalo to conclude thank you very
much to the three of you for your
contribution for sharing
your ideas and your vision and
thanks for the partnership with google a round of
applause for it loyal please
well and now yes now we have reached the
end of what  is this first session
I hope it has been
interesting but this is just the
At the beginning we have worked hard, I
assure you, in the last few months to
prepare content that we hope will
be of interest,
you know that we will have 18
different sessions on three parallel tracks,
one of which will take place in this same
room, which will fundamentally
focus on all the  topics of big data and
machine learning and we are going to have
two other sessions in session 2 and
in session 3 with another six conferences
where we are going to talk about the cuber net, it is about the
development of database mobility
productivity infrastructure applications
In short, many of the things
that only the headlines have told you about
and that we have to prove we
have told you in the morning and I want
to thank our partners and
our clients again with those who
have accompanied us in these first
sessions but you are going to see more we are going to
have more partners and we are going to have more
clients in those sessions that I hope will
be of interest to you  not everything is about the
content of presentations we are going
to feed you and we are going to give you good
food
you will have food from half past twelve
to half past two so that it comes
to the area let's say where the food is
or so that you can take it away
directly to the sessions and there will
also be this snack food throughout
the time so that there is no lack of food and
energy to be able to get the most
out of the sessions and one last
piece of advice and message the partners have made
an important effort to bring a
lot  of content a lot of
experience you have seen what interesting cases they
are working on and I am
sure that some may be
relevant together with the partners there are a
lot of demos there is a community for
developers there are the code lapses with
which I hope there will be something interesting
for  each and every one of you without further ado we
continue at 12 with the rest of the
sessions thank you all very much for
your attendance
[Applause]
[Music]